i want to start with i'm a fan of your
work i thought you did a fantastic job
with this movie thank you for spending
years of your time making it thank you
man so i'm obsessed with the editing
process because that's where like every
movie comes together you're right about
that and your editing is very unique
compared to a lot of other filmmakers
your style and i'm curious what is it
actually like for you how long does it
for say elvis how long is it for you in
the editing room putting this thing
together it's a really good question
i've got this actually
great team i have two editors uh that i
work with maddie and jono a map villa
and jonah redmond
and then they have a vast team around
them but you know you're so right steven
see i look upon editing as writing like
i
write it
then i shoot it but then i keep writing
it in a sense through editorial because
also like i've got a four-hour version i
shouldn't say that what i have i was
about to get to i'm going to get to that
question in a second but i have to make
a two and a half hour version and i have
to serve may not so many like here's
something beautiful like last night
and we didn't expect this but the
presley family have been so suddenly
embracing of the movie they brought us
back to graceland and we had a barbecue
and we go inside the building we're
drinking
in the jungle room hanging
like it's a home and we're in graceland
and we're like being treated to a warm
loving home
i'm sitting there with olivia de jong
and she says
this is crazy because remember you
rebuilt the jungle room she said i've
never been here to graceland this is
exactly like the jungle room set that we
shot in the ghetto elvis recording now i
didn't use that in the movie i just it
didn't
as much as you love that scene you go no
structurally if we go there we're not
going to go on to the drama the next
beat so it's relentless cut and re-cut
try and restyle and i'm even doing
re-voice-overing and pick-ups as i go
through the editorial process i kind of
it's like molding clay i never finish
i i would love to see a longer version
of this movie as a fan of elvis and as a
fan of yours you mentioned you have like
a four-hour cut is that a cut that you
were like happy to show it or is it like
that's an assembly cut it's an assembly
it's a different kind of movie um and i
think right now
this one is i wanted to make a movie for
the theater right i make theatrical
movies my mission is to make a movie
that's not a franchise movie or respect
to franchise
music way i love i love my batman but um
[Music]
i
want to make a movie that across
generations will come in that's not a
franchise and sit in a dark room with
strangers and commune in a vast american
story a vast american opera and that's
what i hope this will be and that's what
i'm fighting for
is to try and bring audiences of all
types back to the theater no doubt in my
mind people are going to come to the
movies to see your community to see your
vision my question is if
you had the ability would you release an
extended cut and if so how long could it
be
so i've just been going through this
experience on i did australia
but hulu is funny the same executive
well hulu have asked me
would i do an episodic version i've just
about finished it and it's actually like
so funny because all of it's what i i
feel like it's a variation on like if
you write a piece of music it's a
variation on so and i think it's a
really legitimate telling it's not just
filler you know
i can't even begin to conceive
what a longer version of this would be
right now
but the idea that there's a different
riff on this theatrical version that's
years down the road it's years down the
road but it's possible but i can't
underline enough it's not tomorrow it's
years down there totally i just as a fan
i would like to see the other things
that you shot that you can't make it in
well i will release a few things that
are just special that maybe didn't make
it into the movie or that are just
special i mean seeing austin i had to
release some footage of austin's costume
test the other day because people simply
don't believe he's singing
the first part of the movie and that was
him just hanging around riffing while we
were looking at costumes
and
still people come back and say yeah but
is he really singing that
you